翻訳: Takafusa Kitazume
校正: Shoko Takaki
こんにちは
古川享です
なんか三途の川の手前から
ちょっと戻ってきちゃったって
感じなんだけれど
最近の若い人にね
これ「大リーグ養成ギブス」
みたいでしょって言ったら
それ何ですか？って言われて
分かった人と分からなかった人は
大体世代が違ってくるんだけれど
今日は最後のセッションで
貴重な機会を頂いて
今日お話しできる機会が本当に嬉しいです
まず最初にお話をしたいテーマとして
「僕たちの好きだった革命」っていうところから
お話をしようと思ってるんだけれど
僕は高校生の時に
麻布高校っていう場所にいて
学園紛争に
巻き込まれたんじゃなくて 自ら駆動してた
やんちゃをしてたんだよ
そのとき勝ち得たのが何かっていうと
学園を我が物顔に
個人の利殖のために
権力者が居たんだけれど
その人間に出て行ってもらって
学園の自由を取り戻した
で尚且つ 制服を廃止してね
今日 制服を着ていくか 私服を着ていくかは
僕らに選ばしてくれ と
授業の内容のカリキュラムは 自分たちが計画したい
そんなことを打ち立てたのが僕らの世代なの
たまたま なんだけれど
今の校長先生が
新中学一年生を迎え入れるときに
麻布には120年の歴史があって
創業者の江原素六先生という方が創業したのが
一回目の創設記念日です と
二回目の創設記念日は
君たちの先輩が
学園の自主と自由を取り戻した日
なんだっていうことをね
新入生に語っていて
ちょっと「自慢」っていう感じで
それで今 文化祭なんか行っても
昔先輩たちが
どうやって その学園の自由を勝ち取ったか
っていうことが未だにね
ちゃんと語り継がれているんだね
そういうことを ちょっと調べてみたら
実は日本の高校生が 安保に反対する
沖縄の返還に対して 自分の意見を言う
ベトナムの戦争に対して
反対をするってことで
暴力的なデモじゃなくて
その当時は「フランスデモ」って言ってね
両手をつないで道にバーッと広がって
道を塞いじゃうようなやり方で
決して人を殴りつけるとか
そういう危険な [ふるまい] ではなしに
人を傷つけないで
自分の主張を社会に訴えかけるっていうようなデモをやっていた高校生たちがいたんだ
その中の首謀者っていうのが私だったんだ
(笑)
実はね (拍手)
高校生のそういった紛争の中で日本全国で
勝利したのは二か所しかなくて
その一か所は札幌の南高校なの
この中にもきっと
南高校の出身者
おられるんじゃないですか
ちょっと手を挙げて下さいよ
いるよね きっと
その人たちがきっと学生の時には
南高校も凄く荒れて
制服の自由を勝ち取り 尚且つ
カリキュラムなどを勝ち取ったっていうのは
麻布と南高校は
その当時から連携をしていたと
そんな背景があるんだ
まず最初に言いたいポイントは
この中にも高校生が沢山いる
それから企業の中で
権力の圧政の中に
自分が もう折れてしまいそうに
なっている人が沢山いるよね
そこから逃げるのも 一つの方法だけど
それ以外に一回
戦ってみるっていうことをね
躊躇しないでほしいっていうことが
一番目のメッセージです
さて二番目に
昔はさ
こんなだった
(笑)
年取るって嫌だよね 本当に
でもね
ASCIIに入社した時に
雑誌の編集に関わって
それで
未来はコンピュータの未来は
こうなるんだって 自ら語って
コンピュータはそのとき
僕は「ビジョンステートメント」っていうのを
コラムに書いたんだけど
将来のパーソナルコンピュータは
小さくなって机の上に
もしくはポケットの中にも
入るようになるかもしれないと
だけど最後には それは
無くなってしまえば良いんだって書いた
もっと重要なことっていうのは
人と人がもっと自由に
人同士が繋がることの方が大事だし
ネットワーク社会の中で
メディアそのものの存在が
もっと重要になってくるって書いてあって
そのメディアの存在っていうのは
その時も書いてある言葉なんだけどね
パーソナルメディアとマスメディアの中間に
新しい双方向性のメディアが
生まれるって書いてあった
それは自分が25歳のときで
1979年の事なんだよね
まだインターネットなんか全然無くて
青山通りの200mくらい離れたオフィスを
512Kbpsでつなぐと ひと月500万円かかった
その頃のメモリーカードは
16Kバイトで28万円した
1200ボーのモデムは50万円した
そんな時代にコンピュータ同士を繋ぐとね
人がもっとスムーズになって
コンピューターそのものを
繋ぐことに意味はなくて
人と人とがもっと
熱いものは熱い
痛いものは痛いって
つなげるような世界が
絶対築き上げられるからって言って
そのときに書いたのが
私の「ビジョンステートメント」なんだけど
その歴史の話をしているんじゃなくて
僕はそれを実現するために
30年頑張ってきた
そういう意味からいうと
マイクロソフトで社長をやったっていうのは ある意味で
遠回りの回り道だったのかもしれない
今 大学院の先生をやりながら
若い人間たちの
良い面構えでしょ
面構えの中の一人に
浅田さんがいるでしょ
こういう人たちに 自分の夢だけじゃなくて
あなたの夢をかなえる為に
僕が力になるよ
僕がジャンプ台をするよっていうことで
実現する社会が
今ちょうど目の前にあるんだよね
ここに来るまでの間に
沢山の壁にぶつかった
自分が意識したのは
まず境界線を越えるための
エネルギーっていうのは もの凄くいる
人生の中で挫折を経験するとかね
へこむって言うことは
こんなに傷ついた人居ないよっていうくらい
傷ついてきたの
その中から這い上がるカラクリ
手練手管を今日は
ちょっと教えようかなと思っているの
一つはね
まず 国境をどうやって超えるか
国境の壁っていうのは やっぱり厚いよね
海も越えていかなきゃいけないし
それから飛行機に乗って
遠くまで行かなきゃいけない
それを越えたら
どういうことが起きるかというと
パスポートには
海外渡航体験480回っていう状態でね
最短はアメリカに10時半に着いて
会議をやって１時の飛行機で帰ってくる
(笑)
もう一日の札幌出張みたいな
状態もやりながら
頑張ってきたんだ
その中で感じた事っていうのが
まず最初にぶつかった壁っていうのが
国境の壁以前に
学歴の壁っていうのにぶつかった
実は僕は今
大学の教授を拝命していますが
高卒なんですよ
大学中退しちゃったから
スティーブ・ジョブズも
ビル・ゲイツも大学中退
私もっていうのは
ちょっと自慢みたいな
(拍手)
やっぱり やりたいことやるためには
途中で投げ出すのもあり
ちょっと方向を変えるのもあり
僕が大学に行ったときには
どんな学問をやりたかったのかっていうと
「性差心理学」っていうのを
やっていたんですよ
男と女はどこで
自分自身の性格を形付けられるのか
そういう学問をちょっとやってた
だけど冷静に考えると
「性差心理学」で就職しようと思うと
ちょっと難しかったていうのがあって
その前にもっと
やばかったのは
大学には一応入ったんだけど
麻布高っていう受験校に行って
大体 東大に80人
早稲田と慶応に150人行くと
大体30人くらいは ちょっとはみ出し者で
演劇をやっている奴もいれば
ゲイバーのママやっている奴もいる
私みたいに ちょっと変わった産業の中で
頑張ってた人間もいたと
その中で 三浪したんですよ
三浪っていうのは 二浪までは人間だけど
三浪っていうのは
人間じゃないって思われてて
付き合ってた彼女なんかも
全員離れていくし
人生 儚んで
もうへこむにへこむっていう状態で
自分の兄はね
丁度
教駒、東大、弁護士っていう
まぁ立派なお兄さんで
それに比べて 弟さんはって言われてね
世間様はよ
そういう風に見るよね
だけど凄くラッキーだったのは
自分の母親は
まったく違う教育を受けながら
別の道を歩んでも 一回たりともね
それに比べてお兄さんと比べてみたいな
そういう教育を一切しないから
勝手にやっていいよっていう自由な中で
自分の生き方を見つけたのは
ラッキーだった
学歴の壁を どういう風に
ぶち破れたかっていうと
実はネットワークの力があった
アメリカで留学をしたときに
８か月くらいの間に
たまたま目の前で インターネットの前に
サイバーネットっていう 南カリフォルニアの大学を
全部つなぐネットワークに出会って
「コンピューター好きなんです」って
図書館の先生に言ったら
だったらスーパーユーザの
IDとパスワードをくれるって言われて
貰ったらね
どの大学でも 入れるんだよね
入試もなしに
繋がった相手は
自分自身の価値を認めてくれて
それで会話が進む
そこにあるものは
どこのキャビネットを開けて
持ってきても良いっていう状態を感じて
え？　これって大学なんか
編入しなくても良いんじゃね？って思って
それでネットワークのパワーっていうのを
自分自身で体験した
その段階で将来
こういう時代が来るんだったら
きっとコンピューターそのものに
個人で戯れて
計算能力だとか 文章を書くとか
そんなことの利便性ではなしに
コンピュータを通じて
人と人とが繋がりあったらね
とてつもないことが起きるなって
いうことを体感したんだよね
その結果
次にぶつかった壁っていうのが 業界の壁
みんな多いでしょ だって
僕はマッキントッシュを使っているんだけど
えーそんなことして
ビル・ゲイツに怒られないんですかって
絶対みんな思うんだよね
それはみんな一人一人が
きっとステレオタイプで
マックの世界はこうで
ウィンドウズはこうでって
それからそれ以外に
スマホを使うなら何とかっていう
概念の中で 自分自身が凝り固まって
ちょっと考えてみなよ
みんなのPCなりマックの環境
それからスマホの環境の中に入っている
一番大事な物は何なの？
OS？違うよね
アプリケーション？それも違うよね
中に入っているコンテンツだとか
メッセージが 一番大事な物のはずなんだ
そういうものを共有できる事の方が
遥かに大事だから
自分が撮った写真が凄く大事で
それを写真集にして 人に提供したいとか
それをみんなで共有したいとか
一つの写真にまた感動してほしいとか
この音楽が大好きだとか
そういうことをやるんだけども
実際には自ら築いている
PCだ マックだ スマホだ
それから まだ壁を壊していないのが
テレビとスマホの関係とかね
もっと良いものに きっとなるはず
デジカメとか家電は まだ繋がっていない
こういうものが
もし繋いだら 最終的にネットワークの中で
自然に 自分の一番心地よい環境を
作ってくようなことができるんじゃないかな
と思っている
それをその壁を壊していこうと
重要なことは 今までは
機能を充実させるってことだったけれども
これから先には ユーザー体験
ユーザーエクスペリエンス UXっていうけど
UIはみんな知ってるかもしれないけれど
UXがもっともっと
大事な事にきっとなってくる
困ったな
後２分でスライド何枚？
(笑)
自分自身は気付きがあった
僕は10年ぐらい前から
岩見沢のクピド・フェアに行って
そこにある身障者の方
障害を持った方と
お年を召した方が 一緒の生活をしていて
お互いを助け合ってるっていう
授産施設に行って
色んな開発をやっているのを
目の前で見てた
最初は 可哀想な人に対して何か施しを
しなきゃいけないっていうような立場でいたら
そんな失礼なことはない
彼らは彼らで 頑張ってるんだから
そんな高いところから
言うようなことっていうのは
本当に失礼だなって
感じるようなことがいっぱいあった
というのは 彼が言ったのは
32歳で大体平均寿命として筋ジスの
患者さんは亡くなっていくんだと
その彼らが言ってくれたのは
いや古川さんもね
80歳になったら絶対こういうものが欲しい
って思うはずだ
僕らは加速度を持って
スピード感を体験しながら
人生 生き抜けているから
あなたが80歳になったときに欲しいものを
私には見えているんだよ
って言ってくれてね
だから それを今から作ってあげるよ
作っておいてあげるから
80歳になるまで待ってなさい
って言われて
かっこいいなって思った
その時に作ってくれたのが
視線だけで文字のエントリーができる
ツールなんだけどね
自分自身の体が動かなくなってくるときに
その視線だけで 人とコミュニケーションが
できるツールを自ら開発して
凄いねって言っていた時に
彼らが自慢をしてくれたのは
札幌のある病院で
交通事故で死にそうになった人が
なんとか家族に
自分の意思と遺書を書いておきたいと
その時に普通のキーボードは
もう触れる体の状態じゃないんだよね
自分たちの道具を
借りに来てくれたんだって
「それが自慢！」って言ってくれて
クピド連中は今でも 自ら生きることと
それから自分自身の持っているものを
例えば老人のために
排泄とか体を洗ってあげるとか
そういうことで苦労してる介護士さんのための
便利な道具を自ら作っている
例えば自ら車椅子を使うだけじゃなくて
車椅子を使う人にとっては
どんなファブリックの生地の
クッションが欲しいかとか
どのくらいのサイズのものが運転しやすいか
っていうことに
自ら気が付いて
それを自由に
設計できるようなネットワークで
設計できるような環境を作ったらいい
というのは本当に学ぶことが多かった
自分自身は雑誌の編集者
プログラマー、営業、事業部長、経営者と
今は大学の教授っていうのを
やっているんだけど
若い人から学ぶ
自ら自分が持っているものを
教えるだけじゃなくて
色々吸収したい
そのために相変わらず
接点を作りたいっていう気持ちで
三途の川の手前から
舞い戻っちゃったんです
終活
脳梗塞ってやってみるとね　(笑)
色々調べてみると
一分間の間に
200万個シナプスが死ぬんだって
そうするともう
段々体が動かなくなって
左半分が全然動かなくなって
体温も左だけ冷たくなると
「あ 俺このまま死んじゃうんだ」
って本当に思うんだよ
今日このまま寝たら
明日目が覚めないんじゃないかって恐怖で
汗かくとね
そこが痒くて
手は持っていけるんだけど 掻けないの
鬼のようなリハビリで
フェイスブックなんかにも書きましたけど
療法士さんが
いやちょっとSっ気がないと療法士さんなんか
やってられませんて言われて
SじゃなくてドSでしょとか言ったけど
本当に鬼のようなリハビリで
手を広げるっていう事だけで一か月
チョキをするのに三か月かかった
今はようやく歩けるようにもなったんだけど
不思議なことにお尻の筋肉が動かないと
足を吊り上げられないんだよね
すると点字ブロックみたいな高さの物に
足をけつまづいて 転びそうになったり
結構大変な思いもしたけど
生き返ったことに対するパワーは
誰から貰ったかっていうと
実はね
これは twitter で語ってた話なんだけど
あなたはドSです
とかそういうことを書いているけど
毎日いろいろメッセージを
発信することによって
こういう療法もあるよ
三か月後くらいに
こういうことを繰り返してたら
どこまで回復するのかなっていうことを
みんなからエネルギーをもらって
自分自身がメッセージを
発信しているだけじゃなくて
SNSの存在が
自分自身の知識を増やしてくれたり
自分自身が
生きる為のエネルギーを僕にくれた
っていうのは 本当に感謝しています
それだったら今度は逆に
自分が返す側として今
舞い戻ってきたっていう
ここで一緒に生活をしている人だとか
学校でみんなに出会う人の中で
へこんでいる奴がいて
くじけそうな奴がいて
そいつを私がエンパワーするために
I'm back したわけです
(拍手)